i'm laura ingram this is ingram angle
from washington tonight we have a lot to
get to so let's dive right in
speaking of freedom matters the freedom
problem that's the focus of tonight's
angle
now back in may of 2020 just a few
months into the pandemic the u.n high
commissioner of human rights
delivered what was actually a surprising
warning
when we restrict certain human rights
because of a need like a natural cause
or a pandemic like this one it has to be
first of all it has to be a clear need
it has to be proportionate to the need
and it has to have a time bound it
cannot be forever we have seen that some
governments are using it to
shrink to make even more shrink the
civic space and the possibility of civil
society to express and that is
unacceptable
how prescient she was two years later
with freedom convoys inspiring millions
around the world
officials who thought they would never
be held accountable
are growing more desperate
the emergencies act will be used to
strengthen and support law enforcement
agencies
at all levels across the country
this is about keeping canadians safe
these tools include strengthening their
ability to impose fines
or imprisonment financial institutions
will be authorized or directed to render
essential services to help address the
situation by regulating and prohibiting
the use of property to fund or support
illegal blockades
what would such a soft pretty man ever
know about keeping anyone safe
not much
weak and ineffective leaders don't
change course even when coveted recedes
because i've said for almost two years
now this was never about the virus
it was about creating a compliant public
a a compliant public that was kind of
primed to obey the next lockdown order
no questions asked
the assaults on our basic liberties have
been wide-ranging
school closures denied children quality
education that was the freedom to learn
vacs and max
vax and mask mandates deprived us of our
freedom to decide what we put into our
own bodies
stay-at-home orders destroyed small
businesses while large corporations
thrived that was our freedom to work
then big tech censorship where youtube
twitter facebook they acted as proxy
speech police for the government our
freedom of expression
anyone who didn't told the fouchy line
even treating physicians and renowned
researchers were threatened they were
suspended maligned and even banned
completely
some lost their jobs
calling something coveted misinformation
gave the government carte blanche
through their proxies to trample on free
expression
now who will ever forget how democrat
governors let you shop together but not
pray together
churches shuddered our freedom to
worship halted
the experts never thought that faith was
essential but somehow they deemed that
liquor stores were
so this anti-freedom coalition on the
left even deployed intimidation squads
in corporate and school settings with
the goal of silencing employees and
parents who spoke out
now take this fascinating case of
jennifer say
she was an elizabeth warren supporter
from the bay area who was forced out of
her high profile job
merely for speaking out against school
closures and lockdowns
now ms say then president of levi
strauss felt passionately about the need
for in-person schooling
she wrote i kept calling out
hypocritical and unproven policies i met
with the mayor's office and eventually
uprooted my entire life in california so
that my kindergartner could finally
experience real school
well back in march 28 21 jennifer
appeared on the angle
whether there's politics involved or not
i i got to take care of my kid
and i want to help all kids because i
realize i'm very lucky that i can pick
up and come here um and i know not
everyone has that that that opportunity
but i will tell you
you know families i know are scraping
together everything they have to either
go to private or move to a district or a
state that's open because at the end of
the day our kids need to be in school
now she's a liberal i'm a conservative
her comments were entirely reasonable
but then she writes
that appearance on this show was the
last straw the head of diversity equity
inclusion at the company asked that i do
an apology tour
i was told that the main complaint
against me was that i was not a friend
of the black community at levi's
i was told to say that i am an imperfect
ally
well then she said she refused to do any
of that
now this woman was on track to be the
ceo of a major company
a liberal with biracial children
cancelled by the corporate mob think
about that
so the left is so freaked out now
because their coveted fortress of rules
and edicts is collapsing before they had
the chance of course to make their new
normal permanent
they're so frantic that they're trying
to stigmatize the word freedom
in other words your freedom kills people
even when they're vaccinated
i love how people talk about personal
freedom
if you're exercising personal freedom of
freedom put someone else in jeopardy
their health in jeopardy
i don't consider that being very
dealing with
freedom now the mocking of freedom has
been a thing of bidens for a while now
two things that concern me
one are those who just try to make this
a political issue freedom
i have the freedom to kill you with my
kobe no i mean come on freedom
never heard a president never thought i
would hear a president say something
like that
and the media picks it up and then
repeats it with their own lame flourish
now the message is to be afraid of those
who want freedom
what you've seen in in canada is others
are fearful of these protesters who are
arguing for freedom now sort of
generically anti-government all wrapped
in this sort of notion or the guise of
freedom you know whatever that means to
these individuals
but freedom for the rest of you to do
and speak your mind no nah they don't
want that here's the way the progs at
the cbc describe the word
it's malleable and a term that thrives
among far-right groups
yet no matter the rubbish they say are
published about this freedom quest
spreading across the globe now the truth
about what the powerful did these past
two years is coming to the fore
it can't be that we live in a country
where freedom only exists for the
connected and wealthy who can go
maskless at the super bowl as third
graders sweated out in n95 masks and
class in la
but they'll always feel justified when
they take away your freedom or when they
skirt the rules
it's going to be that the roads are
dangerous the climate's warming the
variants are coming and almost six years
ago
it was that trump was running
they had to stop him
rules be damned
the left didn't think twice when they
locked the children out of schools and
the clinton campaign didn't think twice
when they deployed internet spies in an
effort to destroy trump and nullify your
vote
even though the ends for them always
justify the means we know what was going
on
and the press they did too
but they didn't cover the stories that
mattered they covered them up
but here's the good news
the anti-freedom coalition is unraveling
and that's the angle
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else